welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
fighting with my family is a comedy
based on the true story of WWE Superstar
Paige and the lady who plays Paige's mom
in this film also very very well known
for the evil Cersei Lannister on Game of
Thrones for which we are huge fans great
to see you Lena Headey here on the Rich
Eisen show what a pleasure to have you
here I'm a big fan I'll just start off
the interview that way I don't care just
you know okay yeah big time a big time
Big Time and I do want to talk about
this film that you are in this
delightful film that you're in about
Paige and her way to WWE stardom how did
you get involved with this film
well I I'd seen the documentary was a
Channel 4 documentary years ago and I
loved it because it's sort of all that
is great about England and our
eccentricities and sort of just being
who you are and so the knight family are
quite extraordinary they're passionate
wrestlers and they raised their kids to
be the best and Paige and her brother
Zack end up auditioning for the WWE and
Paige gets in and she creates history as
the youngest kind of diva to win right
and this and the rock is a producer in
this film he's yeah he's doing Johnson
well so they've met this the part where
they meet in the story and the film is
true she he Mets her own her kind of
whale so when we see him meet her yes
that's actually arena yes what the way
this thing really has yeah so are you
wrestling fan at all of you have you
caught a wrestling fan I used to go when
I was little my dad would take me to
like the janky wrestling what is the
janky wrestling it's there were two
amazing characters they're both dead now
hmm all right P and they were called
giant haystacks and Big Daddy and they
were two really big drinking smoking
wrestlers I mean humongous yeah and they
would just kind of barely slam each
other for hours and like it was really
circusy and crazy my dad would take me
and I was like oh we're gonna go and by
the end I was on my feet and of cheering
because it's such mad entertainment sure
and it's amazing how popular it is it's
always been popular it's yeah it's
immensely popular now today but it's
like the underground theater is giant
was it again you have to look these guys
up so your disability laughs Chris giant
haystacks and Big Daddy whose real name
was Shirley Crabtree come on yeah you
see what they are okay I mean they are
not WWE these guys I can only imagine
the conversation that had to like okay
Shirley we can't throw you out in the
ring as Shirley Crabtree yeah let's
let's workshop here what we can come up
with yeah you have to also he wore like
a unitard you know the ones that kind of
go down yeah well that's that's
old-school wrestling Oh see here's the
unitard you know so all the fruit and
veg on display yeah the produce that's
all out there for sure it's so fresh and
now you're and now you're in a movie
about it and again so what did you learn
about about Paige throughout this whole
process that you you may not have
already learned about story yeah I mean
the document who is fantastic because it
just it shows you you kind of live with
them through this journey and it's just
sort of extraordinary ambition and
passion and drive from this family right
um and then by we did a bit of training
which you kind of think oh you know I'm
kind of physical it's what it's really
really painful well your training it did
what I mean you didn't we did the first
fight in the film we we did that we
learn that whole fight okay which was
really I mean I'm such a tomboy so it
was great fun kind of slamming each
other around the ring right but it's
hard man look it's intense what they do
yeah I mean it's all scripted but you
know it's still you still have to can
you make a mistake you know it's
good yeah the mistake is the bad part
yeah that's for sure yes so you said you
were tomboy
let me ad here on the Rich Eisen show
did you play any sports in the UK
growing up I did I played netball and I
played we played hockey a lot in England
like freezing cold blooney's hockey yes
you were like a grinder in the corner
whatever british hockey what is that
on grass yeah okay that's what I'm sorry
I mean we're we're stupid over here will
read call students certainly okay yeah
so field hockey yeah and I've seen
netball I've seen video of netball I'm
totally confused like still in
basketball
where it's just like the wee wee wee
actually was a video that went viral on
Twitter late last year of the
championship of netball right where
somebody scored from literally six
inches away from the basket after the
referee stopped everybody was like a
free shot from like six inches away and
it went in and then everybody started
celebrating and all of us Americans who
had never seen that ball like yeah so
you you're are you are you well versed
in netball can you what what was that
what do you remember it at all I was
young we had like a minibus that would
take us to little talk you know
tournaments yeah against the other
schools okay I played Center which is
the one that can go everywhere right
yeah and you can school mmm
but we used to swap it was just fun okay
all right so you had some game a little
bit of game is a very I'm sure yeah now
did you shoot fighting with my family
before or after the last season of Game
of Thrones before okay so this is in
between anything else
no look I've interviewed Kit Harington
before okay and I know that it's like a
vault it's like you would be icy you
could get anything else
he didn't he didn't really give anything
away he's good he was pretty good yeah
it was pretty good maybe had lessons so
you're now you're assuming I'm gonna try
and get something out of you mm-hmm no I
don't want I want to be surprised
okay then we're good but I have read I
have read that you know that you you
were part of the last day of shooting
right
well my I mean my last day your last day
yes was not technically the last day of
shooting No
and that's giving nothing that's giving
nothing away we don't shoot in any order
okay now you strike me as a very lovely
person
Lina this is true okay you strike me as
a very lovely person with a with a great
personality and very sweet how the hell
do you become Cersei Lannister how the
hell does that happen uh the real me I
keep her hidden no I mean it's to play
the bad guy yes just such good fun you
don't I mean I can do all the things I
can't really do in my life it's not like
I'm like trying to think like is there
is there some form of evil concoction
underneath this show studio that could
go up at any point in time Nate is all
out
maybe I planted it any lookout oh so you
just love just chewing up the scenery
and and doing that it's what we do when
you first got the first ever game of
Thrones script yes what did you think
when you first got it no one will ever
watch this no kidding yeah why did you
think that I think because we were or
when you shoot a pilot there's kind of
no money and so it's it was really funny
there was no there were no chairs for us
it was kind of bonkers what do you mean
but because there was no money put into
it so we do pilot it's like we don't
know if it's gonna go or not so you just
go make it like in a tent in the cold
and so we were like what are we doing
you know and then it came out and it was
just people loved it and so I guess we
all start going oh I guess when we're
gonna have jobs this is amazing
so the are you saying the Iron Throne
was initially made of like spray-painted
styrofoam is that what you're saying yes
no I might just like you know like it
was just the the craft shop just threw
it all
pilot somewhere completely different and
then we finally moved to Belfast and we
had stages and all that stuff so you
know things like that
obviously just it makes sense they grow
and they grow and so every year we were
like oh I guess we're really this is
really a thing did you know that your
did you know that your character was
gonna survive season 1 even before you
took the game you did oh yeah yeah I
knew up until the walk of shame like
that was that was the beginning to the
end and then I didn't know beyond that
you mean when you first got the gig you
knew that you were gonna live to the
walk because of the books is that what
you're saying no no David and I'm like
this is what we have for her like this
is where she goes the walk of shame
planned out all the way from Jump Street
yes no kidding I mean those boys are
very clever they they had a plan all
along for all of us
and it was you know the reveals were
slow and that's what makes it so
exciting
so then season 6 script comes you're
flipping through the pages that you
Baker write every season all right then
what about the final season when you got
the script what did you do with that
same thing I think all of us were like
okay so which one was happiest by the
end I can tell you that was creative see
I didn't but by the way for the radio
audience I didn't even look at you when
I said that I was looking down at
anything I just like I'm not gonna look
at her when I say that I mean maybe I'll
actually get an answer who are you most
concerned from the cast that is actually
gonna give something away okay but
that's good he's passed the test what do
you mean you can just butter him up with
a bit of booze we've got so much around
here too gonna book him again and just
you know that's just water and all oh my
gosh well I asked him this question I
will ask you this what is the craziest
fan theory for your character that has
been presented to you by a fan I mean I
haven't read the things I've you know
I've seen people have sent me stuff
where they're like she's gonna turn into
you know the night Queen and stuff like
that
crazy is it is it crazy or is it
possible yeah basically he said the one
was that everybody thought that he was
the he's a dog that he's one of the
direwolf interesting could that be true
Oh see now you're just trying to look
just trying to throw out all these other
Easter eggs here okay I have a game
called start bench cut it's like you
know blank marry kill where you have to
choose one as their start one bench and
you have to cut one you have to say that
this person is not going to be involved
here okay these are sports terminologies
yes let's play play start bench cut with
Lena your own okay the most imaginative
form of revenge by Cersei Lannister okay
you have to start one that's your number
one choice bench is number two and you
have to cut one one they said you're not
really into okay okay you you gave the
nun who shamed you to the mountain you
killed everyone literally everyone with
wildfire or the kiss of death to ilaria
sans daughter right in front of her I
would start by giving scepter nella to
the mountain that's your favorite one
yes Bench the wildfire and cut Lauria
although oh they got to tell you though
the wildfire when that happened the
whole room I was in because again you
watch this with just 10 15 people yeah
went crazy they didn't I mean literally
like jaw hitting the floor because that
is some serious and then you just
watching it from afar yeah just having
some wine is there wine in there no it's
like some weird like some weird laxative
next one things that made Joffrey
Baratheon so evil start bench cut the
pressure of being king since birth the
fact that his uncle is actually his
father pampering by his mother yes
ruffian bench and the other one cup just
really that the pressure being king
since
he cut that yes it's no pressure just it
was my fault it was all my face you
blame it on the mother yes you blame it
on the mother alright next one which
Game of Thrones season was the worst for
Cersei season four when Joffrey and
Tywin went down season five when the
high Sparrow led to the walk of
atonement or season six when Tommen you
know I think we're gonna have to start
with the walk of shame because that was
pretty awful
I think Tommen not too happy dad
didn't really love him so we'll cut that
okay what was the walk of shame scene
like for you uh it was long we did it
was three days and three days yeah we
did it in kind of sections and because
they had to hide us all from the
tourists and stuff and brilliant Rebecca
who was my body double and so we would
just kind of tag team in and out the
whole three days three days
yeah that's insane that is oh my gosh
alright and I've got the last one for
you here the best badass the mountain
Dwayne Johnson the rock or Cersei
Lannister start bench cop yeah you know
yes I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna cut
the mountain cuz he's dead anyway and
he's a zombie I think says he could take
the rock okay
she's gonna start he's gonna bench
you're gonna bench the rock and start
your own okay look it's okay we're gonna
make sure that the two of you get
together I have met the mountain yes yes
oh my god he's the hugest an individual
I've ever met yeah tire like it's
bonkers yeah I are the amount of food he
consumes what do you mean I was like we
have to cut because a half Thor has to
have his seventh chicken of the day he
dominates craft service yes he does he's
I mean they literally bring him like a
feast at read our said he doesn't faint
he just kind of eat that's amazing
that's some quality information alright
so yeah so I don't even know what to ask
because you're not gonna give anything
away at all okay weird okay where are
you gonna watch the finale you yourself
Lena Headey uh probably just on
so far with my tiny children no I'm not
I'm gonna watch it with some mates with
some okay just toast off yes sir see ya
what an amazing amazing nine years okay
so Cersei Lannister will be in the
finale of Game of Thrones I think I just
learned that did I just get that out did
I just worry anxiety it sounded pretty
good okay let's go did you shoot
alternate endings to throw anybody off
do you think oh that's a shrug of the
shoulders I know nothing they're
questioning anything this is okay I'm
done we do what we're I'm trying my best
you are awesome by the way you're
awesome
in this film again that everyone should
see in me in theaters nationwide this
Friday it opened up on both coasts on
Valentine's Day fighting with my family
it is just it's a fun fun fun movie and
you don't even need to be in wrestling
to actually I love the story and then
you are awesome in Game of Thrones on
behalf of me and all my friends and my
wife she can't get she just loves you
man
absolutely Lena Headey here on the Rich
Eisen show I am Lena Headey on twitter
as well as instagram check her out
fighting with my family in theaters
nationwide on the 22nd this very Friday
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience